good to see you good to see you thanks
for having me - you bet Pro Football
Hall of Famer Andre Reed is here in
studio great to see you you just we just
talked about how you have your Hall of
Fame ring on did you recently misplace
your jacket Andre Reed is that I
recently misplace everything man I'm
just I don't know some of them days you
know you're just know where you're at
yeah I did I was in Atlanta mm-hmm
actually doing a vent there for the Boys
and Girls Club which I'm a part of yeah
and I was waiting for my brother
actually I was in Pennsylvania you're
sorry okay waiting for my brother on the
curb and had my two bags in my garment
garment bag there yeah and just got in
the car and left my garment bag on the
sidewalk just totally just totally just
blew a fuse Hall of Fame jacket went to
the garment into the garment bag with a
couple other things and I got home and I
was like I thought I brought three bags
and it just so happened that I had my
name and my phone number cuz I just got
the got the coat cleaned and the cop
called me from the airport in Philly he
said hey I think we have your bag and I
was like wow I was like I got some
problems so if you did not have your
you're Hall of Fame jacket dryclean but
they still it still says Andre Reed
inside yeah but I had but still I don't
know how we looked at it that way and
how to contact you - yeah so you have
that was good Lord you know looking out
for me again amazing yeah let's hold on
to that man what do you think of the
record that Brady broke last night
what's more impressive five hundred
touchdowns in a career or 71 different
receivers catching touchdowns for Tom
Brady I think five hundred touchdowns I
mean they're both extraordinary feats I
mean Tom Brady is terrific Tom what else
can you say about him mm-hmm five Super
Bowl rings the guy's breaking records
every time he steps on the field 500 T
DS who get out more of Peyton Manning
and Brett Favre correct sir maybe Drew
Brees someday Drew Brees is gonna break
the record this week for away from doing
that but Brady's the only one to have
done
with the same team yeah well then that's
even more so
he's been there what 17 years 18 years
and how England how difficult is it for
a quarterback to keep throwing
touchdowns to so many different
receivers over the years Andre but it
seems like New England just knows how to
pick guys up from the grocery store you
know they they got guys that you they're
not household names and they don't have
the big name like some of the these
these teams have today in the league but
they buy into the system and once you
buy into a system it doesn't matter
who's out there you're you're and then
you have Tom Brady thrown to you then
you have Bill Belichick kind of yelling
at you to so but you buy into a system
and if you believe in that system it
doesn't matter who's out there this is
what we want you to do it is where we
want you to be the own time all the
things that Bill Belichick kind of puts
on the on the table for all these guys
and they go out and play on Sundays and
it's hard to beat them it's hard to beat
that kind of mentality it's amazing
they're not so simple the way you say it
so why does why don't other people do it
everybody's been trying to do it for how
many years they've been to class at AFC
four since Brady's been there along with
Pittsburgh and and a couple of these
other teams but you have to beat New
England most of the time to get to us I
know but that but what I mean
Andre Reed here in the Rich Eisen show
is that every coach has a system of
course every coach has a a a rule of law
that they try to bring to a locker room
and get somebody to buy in right Marv
levy clearly had that of course back in
the day and how long did it take for you
guys to buy into what he was selling I
think you know everything all of Fame
number 12 as well yes sir I think every
coach has a different philosophy again
buying into the system and then how do
you get all those players to be on the
same page every single Sunday that's
hard to do in this league now because
everybody's individualized everybody
wants to do dances I mean we saw that
you make a tackle and you want to go all
the way to the other end zone and do a
dance or whatever you want to do it's
just a it's just a different player in
the last 10 15 years and it was mm-hmm
you know years ago when I played
not saying that they're not team players
but every seems like every guy has an
agenda how do I do this when I do this
I'm gonna do this you guys were to go
out there and play and help your team
win that's the most important thing but
how how long did it take for you guys in
Buffalo uh Marv that's a good question
because we went through a couple
coordinators like a lot of people do we
had ten marchibroda it's starting just
playing together and you know when you
play together with a bunch of guys for a
long time there's no other way that you
can't be good because if you're not then
you're not gonna be there
they bring somebody else in which is
what New England does a lot they pick
guys up from the waiver wire that you
don't think that could play and you're
like who scored that touchdown oh that
guy that guys you know playing well for
them all year so you just got to be on
the same page I mean that's the main
thing and it doesn't matter who that
player is we add Reggie Wayne who I
think is gonna be in the same of course
you one day soon we had it last week and
he was saying that it's not easy when
you're Antonio Brown to have some kid
like juju Smiths Shuster show up and
start eating into your catches and
touchdowns it's not easy for someone
like Julio Jones to watch Calvin Ridley
come in and grab touchdowns certainly if
you're not winning right did you ever
have that with Lofton um not really you
know what cuz I knew every time he
stepped on a field he was gonna make me
better and by making me better that
makes the next person better and then we
are better as a team and we win which is
the most important thing winning you're
gonna get stats I mean this is a
passingly you know you can bring anybody
on here it's a passing Football League
mm-hmm they want points scored defenses
are still stout in their own way they
want to stop stop people I mean look at
Kansas City right now in the ramps
they're the two best teams in the game
Kansas City's a little bit shaky on
defense but the Rams got studs on
defense they you know what Donald and
Sue in the two corners even though two
leaves out but then you bring that
offense along with Jared Golf is doing
with Gurley up they got so many weapons
Patrick mahomes is just tearing the
league up
this is a kid that did I think that he
was gonna be the player he's gonna be I
think Andy Reid is just giving him the
keys and said just drive the car
and you got the cheetah out there and
you got Sammy Watkins and it's not like
kareem hunts having the game you know
the season he had last year so far but
you bring him along and again they're
hard to stop with mahomes back there so
something's gotta give
did you hear what Jalen Ramsey had to
say about the cheetah he wants to turn
him into a like a little minute let's
let's let's get that soundbite up for
for Andre Reed here no this is Jalen
Ramsey yesterday okay talking about
Tyreke he'll when asked about the
matchup with Ramsey and Hill coming up
this weekend because what Jalen had to
say he's good for what he does for a
team you know he may all pro as a return
specialist let's get that right as a
retired specialist his rookie year he
went to two promos as a return
specialist return specialist two years I
made all-pro in my position as a corner
went to the Provo has a corner so it's
not a wide receiver vs or dementia Wow
but you know what I think Jalen has been
saying that kind of stuff ever since he
came in league and obviously he's if not
the best corner in league's top five
mm-hmm
you know when I played it was Deon and
Rod Woodson all those guys they just
didn't have that kind of mentality I
mean D I might have talked a little bit
and I think Jalen backs it up but I
think he when he hears himself talk that
hypes him up more and and of course
media loves that kind of thing and he
loves they love talking when he played
Odell two weeks ago
every good corner wants to be on their
best player
Jalen's a good corner great corner wants
to be on their best player and that's
Tyreke Hill this week so lobby's a
return specialist touch that's true
that's true but he's earned specialist
the way I just heard it how do you think
the return specialist is handling that
in
I'm just probably a lot of return yeah
it's not too happy about that but again
everybody loves talking this is this is
a he just wants somebody to talk back at
him and again he's probably a top corner
league and he backs it up but it's good
for media and I think we don't trust me
by the way I think the football guy I'm
sure if he was hitting here he'd talk
about you well interestingly enough he
sat behind me at a the NFL honors this
past year how was that oh I reminded him
of what the seating chart looked like oh
you were in front of yes oh yes I don't
know how longer I will be but no yeah oh
yeah so I think it's gonna be a great
match I mean this weekend's games are
gonna be awesome
yeah I know but Tyreke and Tyreke he'll
do you think that the locker room or the
Andy Reid is gonna try and feed now and
a rate based on Andy's not that guy cut
cheese he won't take that cheese I gotta
take that bait who was that who is the
best trash talker when you were playing
you know what I again I talked about
it's just a such a different game I
never there's nobody to actually talk
trash come on really I never really had
a guy who'd talk trash you know like
constantly you know maybe sometimes a
you know today is gonna be one of these
days you know it's gonna be a long day
and I was like yeah today is gonna be a
long day for you too so that's the way
it went yeah that was it I think the
respect factor and I'm sure these guys
respect each other I hope they do hope
they do because if you don't respect
somebody you're gonna you're gonna get
burned up quick and I just didn't I
could just can't tell you one guy okay I
can say that's not even that's not trash
that's not garbage that's that's not
even recycling that's not even white boy
yeah didn't nobody trash talk on your
team at all
oh we had a bunch of guys at Wrestle
okay now there we go who is that
yeah well you know Thurman all those
guys a hayward Bruce Thurmond biscuit
yeah Darryl Talley all the defensive
guys did the most trash-talking so there
were no defenders that would be talking
trash to you then no then I remember you
know that really kind of was in my head
and I couldn't you know do what I wanted
to do okay Andre Reed here Pro Football
Hall of Famer in the Rich Eisen show
what do you think of Josh Allen the
current state of the bills
great kid a quick story I met him at the
draft this year and we were all in a
room all that you know the top 15 16 or
20 guys being drafted on the first day
and Roger Goodell and Jim Brown and you
had a bunch of other players Steve
Atwater we're just kind of just bringing
these kids into and say hey this is what
you're getting into
okay it is now what you did in pass is
how are you gonna handle yourself as a
professional and it was just a meet and
greet not and it's ironic that I really
gravitated to Josh Allen right away and
we ended up picking him the second I say
we know the bills picked him seven the
pick and he wanted to know what what was
what's Buffalo like I was like it was
crazy
I praise his fans in the NFL I said you
get picked by us you're coming into a a
serious fan base that loves your team
that wants to win and that's when you
come in there that's what you got that's
the mentality you got to have you gotta
have a winning mentality because we
haven't won in a while we haven't been
into playoffs and you know we're in the
playoffs last year the first time in 17
years so and then we end up picking him
and I'm I'm just proud of him because
it's not that he doesn't have a lot to
work with I mean Shaun McDermott is a
great coach he's a good coach but he's
got a lot of young guys this is a young
football team and they're just trying to
feel themselves out they you know put
all this together and it's it's tough
man and with a young squad but two weeks
ago he showed that he's a leader you had
confidence and they just got to get
everybody around him to play better yeah
I mean that just came out of nowhere
yeah I never thought he would yeah he
flying over people and jumping over
buildings and stuff like that I was I
was pretty good
Anthony ball yeah just anybody yeah
diving into end zones I think that
really showed not only what kind of
player he could be but it just showed
that team right there on that get in
that game going into Minnesota and
beaten Minnesota was in NFC championship
last year that okay I want this to be my
team and you know we'll see what happens
so you just got to be on there they get
they all got to be together you know
with him the Andre Reed foundation
helping underprivileged children reach
their full potential and become
responsible contributors to their
commune
for the last eight years established me
ten what's the Reed with Reed
eighty-three program here well it's a
national literacy program that started
about a year and a half ago through the
Boys & Girls Club of America I'm a Boys
and Girls Club kid I grew up in the
clubs and along with Denzel and J Lo and
Shaq were all Club kids and I go around
doing speeches for them across the
country and it's ironic that as a kid I
didn't when I went home at night I
didn't have people you know my mom and
dad read to me and reading is so
important that you want to tell these
kids they love to exercise outside and
they love to run around but you got to
exercise your brain too and and it's
important you know one really telling
stat eighty-three percent my number
which is which is ironic of kids in
poverty can't read past third grade so
there's a lot of telling stats that
really make a literacy real real
important reading thirty minutes a day
and all these little things that they
got to do because it's they're gonna
it's gonna be if they do that they'll
become more successful in life and
that's what my program does and we're in
fifteen NFL cities right now we want to
be in all 32 and so we take kids to a
game we you know they read enough books
they get to move their football they
score touchdowns and then they go to a
game and meet the owner they meet the
players down on the field they get VIP
status it's awesome so it's it's a great
incentive program for these kids that
realize that it's important in life
sponsored by the Boys and Girls Clubs
Andre Reed foundation.org check it and
it's powered by their INSCOM fantastic
yes good to see you sir
great to see this first of hopefully
many times like you got it no problem
let's talk some ball throughout the
season you got it Andre Reed check them
out on Twitter Andre underscore read 83
we're back with the 844 204 rich number
2 down here on the showed the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience